bueno
[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la variante
de 1 617 el coronavirus que fue
identificada por primera vez en india el
pasado octubre se ha convertido en la
cuarta considerada de preocupación según
la organización mundial de la salud esta
decisión se ha tomado en consulta con un
grupo de trabajo que ha seguido la
evolución del virus a partir del
análisis de más de 4500 secuencias
genéticas procedentes de 44 países donde
esta variante ha sido detectada para
hablar sobre este tema quiero saludar en
este momento al doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia además
asesor científico de france24 doctor muy
buen día gracias por estar con nosotros
nuevamente le pregunto cuáles son las
preocupaciones que expresa la o ms
frente a esta variante india
es muy importante reconocer que las
variantes van a suceder y que estas
variantes tienen un factor crítico que
es el número de contagios entre mayor
número de contagios haya mayor
probabilidad que estos linajes en
diferentes países o en diferentes local
se les aparezca en india debido al gran
incremento de casos aparece un nuevo
linaje que repercutirlo interés por su
contagiosidad y entra dentro de la
monitoría de la organización mundial
porque está en varios países y
probablemente voy a tener mayor
compromiso en otros países dependiendo
de la migración mal ahora doctor ya hay
tres variantes que la anteceden la
sudáfrica a la reino unido y la
brasileña de esta región preocuparse por
su liga
claro estas variantes se ponen de
interés por su primero porque los vinos
no tienen fronteras dependen mucho de la
migración humana como les decía pero
estas variantes también pueden ser
predominantes dentro de la diseminación
en un país y pueden tener repercusiones
dentro del comportamiento de la dinámica
de la pandemia haciendo picos nuevas
solas anticipando picos o extendiendo
las los picos que hay entonces estos
linajes son preocupantes para nuestra
región y para todas las regiones del
mundo por eso es una gran preocupación
estamos en monitoreo de todo lo que pasa
en la línea doctor qué tan alta en su
tasa de transmisión y qué tan letal
puede ser esta variante
es mucho más contagiosa lo que
encontramos en los estudios decir que es
mucho más eficaz su transmisión ya no
son tantos minutos que se emite
exposición sino son muy pocos minutos
para poder adquirir este virus y al ser
mucho más contagio se infecta mayor
número de personas y al infectar a mayor
número de personas pues la mortalidad se
incrementa porque hay un mayor número de
sujetos enfermos entonces en la
mortalidad está relacionado con el
incremento de los casos pero
definitivamente es mucho más eficaz su
transmisión que otras variantes que se
están desarrollando el informe
epidemiológico semanal publicado por la
mamá se explica que esta última variante
en incorporarse al grupo es de las más
preocupantes y requiere de un
seguimiento cercano porque contiene tres
sub linajes qué significa esto doctor
recordemos que en el virus hay variantes
y dentro de las variantes hay mutaciones
mutaciones que hacen que sea una
variante de un número de otros número de
autónoma no esta variante hindú tiene
tres mutaciones y estas tres mutaciones
son las que le permiten adquirir una
mayor capacidad de contagio 2 mayor
posibilidad de escape al sistema
inmunológico y 3 podría impactar
negativamente con las vacunas entonces
es este el linaje tiene 3
con digamos tres cambios en el genoma
que hacen que tenga un interés especial
porque tiene capacidad de escapar del
sistema inmune mayor contra diversidad y
disminución de la inmunización de la que
sea efectiva la inmunización doctor
carlos por el tumor me pregunto pueden
las variantes reducir la efectividad de
las vacunas contra el coi 19
afortunadamente la mayoría de vacunas
han funcionado bien contra los linajes
que conocemos las vacunas de hernia
funcionan contra los linajes de manaus
del reino unido- y cada vez hay más
evidencia acerca de esa seguridad con la
variante hindú de estamos en la
incertidumbre están desarrollándose los
estudios para mirar cómo se comportan
algunas vacunas no son útiles con o tan
útiles con unas variaciones esperamos
los estudios en las próximas semanas
pero probablemente en la reducción en
algunas de las vacunas con estado de
antídoto estamos por documentar lo y
estamos pendientes de la información así
es doctor y por supuesto aquí también la
vamos a publicar cuando eso sea posible
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en france 24 hasta aquí 5
minutos con hace una próxima oportunidad
buen día
[Música]